hi I'm Lisa talansky founder of brave
new talent com and here in Davos is a
wide yell and I've been tasked with
asking answering a question from a
student at high school called king alex
178 and kim alex asked us what could I
student from high school do to support
the economy of my country I'm so great
question i think the the best answer I
can give to this is to do whatever you
can to reach your own full potential so
there's a lot of ways you can think
about reaching your full potential and
start to look at who can mentor you who
you can look up to you can be inspired
by and you can use technology to to find
those people and to learn new things
because I think one thing that's unique
about your generation in fact my
generation is that we're the first
generation entering the workforce that
is actually an authority on some lattice
you are the authority on social media
your question is here at the social
media tent you have the authority on
technology on the change that's bringing
about so so I'm very passionate about
entrepreneurship I highly encourage it
and think about what steps you can take
to reach your full potential because the
majority of people in the world do not
ever get to reach their full potential